hey Becca can I have another boat you
already have tons of boats no I don't
what's that this is just a pontoon boat
and what's that this is just a skill and
what's that
I don't think kayaks who care does this
fun couch no I only use this for shark
fishing and and this one this is a
stand-up paddleboard
not a stand-up paddle boat and what
about the paddle boat it was on sale
Luke you can't buy any more boats I
won't buy any more boats
Luke and Jake here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel it is a cold winter
morning and a perfect day to build a
floating fishing cabin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I got a lot more done today that I
thought I was gonna get and if you guys
want to see kind of a list of materials
and some plans and details about this
project I'm gonna post it on Facebook
and put a link to that post in the video
description so if you want to do this at
home you can figure out how to do it but
I've got to get to bed and I will see
you guys in the morning
all right it's another beautiful day oh
[Music]
[Music]
my back's killing me I'm gonna call for
the day and I'll see you guys tomorrow
well it's day three of this project and
it's one of the few days that's warm
enough to paint so we're gonna go ahead
and do that today
unfortunately it's supposed to rain so
we have to do it all in the garage here
and it's just barely enough room to
paint here in the garage I've got some
exterior deck paint we're gonna slap on
there and let's see what happens there
you go guys is your first glimpse at the
size of this project four units making a
total of 16 feet by 8 feet all right
let's get painting
[Music]
I slapped about a half a gallon the
paint on there we're gonna let that dry
for about four hours then we're gonna
hit the sides and the bottom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we've made pretty good progress on
this project but my little boys decided
to bring home stomach flu so for the
last few days I've been doing other
things stop pooping we're gonna get back
on this got one more wall panel to make
and the roof and then we're gonna start
putting things together all right a lot
of you guys are wondering how we're
gonna make this raft float and to do it
we're gonna use 18 gallons Sterlite bins
from Walmart they run about three four
dollars apiece so they're super cheap
and the dimensions are perfect each one
of these bins will fit perfectly into
one of these squares you get 10 bins per
raft and we have four rafts that will
form together to make one big raft so
that's 40 bins now if you want to know
how much these can hold do some simple
math one gallon of water weighs eight
point three four pounds 18 gallons of
water the volume of one of these bins is
roughly a hundred and fifty pounds ten
bins is 1,500 pounds for rafts 40 bins
is 6,000 pounds so it takes about six
thousand pounds to sink 4018 gallon
Sterilite bins now obviously we don't
want to sink it we want to have a margin
of safety
we only want about a third
the bin to be submerged in the water we
want the raft to sit nice and high out
of the water so that we have some safety
in case of waves or bouncing around so
if you only want a third of the raft to
be submerged then you take that six
thousand number divide it by three and
that's two thousand pounds is the max
safe load of the raft fortunately I have
more than just a theoretical knowledge
about how these bins work I've built
rafts like this before and floated
rivers on them I took a troop of Boy
Scouts down the James River one year on
a bunch of rafts made out of bins like
this a matter of fact a lot of these
bins are left over from that project and
it worked great the things floated like
corks and they handled class two Rapids
very nicely these eighteen gallon
Sterlite bins come with a quarter-inch
hole right here in the handle and that's
how we're going to attach them to the
deck of the raft all of these bins are
old bins that I recycled for my old raft
projects and you can see some of them
have done multiple whitewater trips and
you can see where they've been hit stuff
it's left a little white scuff mark but
very few of these vents break and when
they do we just replace it
I went and made a whole bunch of these
little wood washers here and we're gonna
take and put them just like that down
there one down 80 more to go alright
that's the foundation of our fishing
platform and cabin 16 feet by 8 feet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
works all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at this she's looking gorgeous now
a little bit of light inside just enough
to see boy yeah everything's working
good well everything seems to be working
great but my wife wants this off our
front lawn so I think I need to break it
down and put it on that trailer
there you go eight bolts in 40 nuts
that's all that holds this thing
together
[Applause]
come aboard and lay my lady there we go
we got our electric power grab by
children we've taught you well raise
yourselves not going fast but you know
we're getting a mile per hour to the
Love Boat siding and for sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there we go it's all together so
long suckers about to have the best care
of my life well here we are with the
maiden voyage of the floating fishing
cabin we've got the whole Nichols family
aboard and it's doing really well we're
not we're not to back heavy the nose
isn't sticking up too high it's riding
evenly that's good very stable the wind
doesn't seem to make it want to tip over
which was another concern we're using a
little bit more free board that I
thought we would right now the bends are
about halfway submerged so we still have
about that much from the top and so
we're doing pretty good there but yeah I
wouldn't want to load it up too much
guys I think we should go camping on the
fishing cabin
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go you guys ready to do some
fishing and camping we're going we're
cranking yeah we did
high-fives get the skiff going behind us
yeah I'm really glad we got the window
in the back because we can see what's
going on with the boat back there nice
of y'all to see behind you this is sick
I just saw some shadow maybe we should
try to get some bait we've got a great
spot that I think will produce some good
fish here so we're gonna go and post up
right here some really shallow water and
we're gonna be able to access the
shallow stuff and the deep stuff and to
hopefully get some good fishing in
[Music]
well guys sunsetting honest I think it's
time to do some fishing let's catch some
big old catfish we're gonna use some
pieces of cut-up shadows bait well I
thought I saw some carp jumping so I'm
gonna make up some carp bait
unfortunately I forgot to bring any corn
so I'm just gonna use jell-o panco grits
throw it on a method feeder and we're
gonna see if we can't catch some carp
[Applause]
I'm going to take a little glob of grits
and panco and we're gonna squish it on
to the method feeder like this and we're
going to take this little fake piece of
corn jam it in there see if we can't
catch a carp guys I can't believe it
it's taken weeks but finally we're doing
it we're camping in our floating fishing
cabin that we built ourselves and we've
got the rods out it's beautiful we're
safe I've just having a ball they're
starting to get a little hungry so I
think it's it's time for dinner you guys
hungry
Oh do that look at this over here on
this corner see what you got
keep them out from that log in under
don't low get up wrapped around the boat
motor Oh Oh a nice carp beautiful carp
Tom congratulations bud put him up back
in there good job buddy
Wow slimy high-five there we go
oh that smells so good
put these sweet peppers in there
[Music]
wonderful bit right there here have some
peppers just to eat some vegetables okay
this is probably one of the best camping
trips we've ever done this is pretty
nice just sittin here eatin steak with
my boys looking out over our rods
life is good oh hey guys look a bite
grab it really quick don't let him get
it take a look at the other stuff well
we had to carp on landed one gotten some
bites of the catfish rods we're off to a
good start these socks are so wet my
boots have holes well the temperatures
dropping quickly that's supposed to get
in the 30s tonight so it's a little
chilly right now but but we're nice and
cozy in here the boys are cuddle up it's
getting past their bedtime and we're
just gonna kind of snooze and watch our
fishing rods and have a good time Oh
guys this is so nice I got this toasty
little propane heater here you got my
memory foam fishing cot Tom Tom I just
by reeling the rod and there's a fish
right there for everyone the big fish
he's fighting hard you go get warm
let's get it back in the water dump Pole
this is a load of fun but it's ten
o'clock and I've got to get the kids to
bed so I'm gonna reel em up and we're
gonna get to bed okay
good night did you sleep well last night
yeah well shake it off and make some
food boys
[Music]
I'm sitting here filming a YouTube video
while Nathan's watching one of my
youtube videos my life is like movie
Inception so yeah we got some mountain
house biscuits and gravy here we're
gonna turn it this out I just found out
sausages cooking let's do some fishin
[Music]
got the rods out I'm gonna go inside and
hang out with the boys wait for a bite
because I've been a floating vision
Gavin it's just a cold miserable day
outside this is just so Pleasant sitting
here with the heater on the boys are
snuggled up in their little bags just
man I don't think I could get the boys
out fishing camping in this weather if
it wasn't for this cabin well we've got
a fish on and I think everyone wants to
stay warm air so committee go deal with
it oh yeah there he is
you put me in that same well darn it I
just lost another carp and another carp
rig in that snag over there so I have
started with three rigs I'm down to only
one rig and one rod for carp I really
came here expecting to catch a lot of
catfish
he's gotta use up that steak you guys
won an early lunch
oh it is cold and rainy out here fish
haven't been doing much so I think we're
gonna reel it up and go take the boat
out for a little cruise and just see how
it's doing after a night out on the
water there we go just out for a little
sailing trip on our floating fishing
cabin all right guys have just doing a
little inspection from the outside and
check her out look at that she rides
pretty well in that water it's a good
looking ship right there I am super
happy with this project if you guys like
this type of video make sure to click
that like button and we'll do more
camping trips and fishing trips in this
cabin if you want to see more fishing
check out my other channel the catfish
and carp YouTube channel I've got 500
videos on fishing and if you want to see
more camping and survival videos we got
that here at the outdoor Boyz Channel
too so we'll put links in the
description to some of our survival
camping trips which are pretty fun so
thanks for watching don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos
like this don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
belt button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching